Usually the universe will send us a message.
This message is the next step in our personal and spiritual development;
the lesson that we need to learn to grow, and if you ignore the universe, it'll just get louder
Oh a phone call
*awkward chuckle*
What is this a personal attack?
and louder
You can't ignore me Anna, this is the universe
I have a very important message for you.
Okay, I need you to know your value.
until finally, it seems kind of ridiculous.
in theory, Would you want this...
twenty dollars?
In theory? Yeah, but I guess also in reality, Yeah.
even if I did this?
uhh...
Yeah?
what about this?
Yeah, I mean it's still $20
what if I farted on it?
no, actually I would definitely pass in that case,
okay, well, I mean never mind then but like
isn't it nteresting that no matter how much I beat up this twenty-dollar bill
it still has its inherent value?
*sighs*
Okay, I get it!
who are you talking to?
So for the last few years, my one goal has been to
recognize my self-worth and to practice self-love, and you know, in the midst of things it's really hard to tell whether or not change is
actually happening but, a few months ago,
someone I've been seeing romantically told me
so I've like, decided, I don't actually want a relationship anymore, but don't worry
I'm still down to like chill and have all the perks of a relationship without any of the emotional accountability
Now freeze on my big, dumb, stupid face!
old Anna would have a hundred percent said
Oh, yeah, of course. That's tight, Right. That's like a solid deal. Yeah I mean, that's exactly what I want that lines up
While inside I would have thought...
why don't they like me enough to commit, you know
maybe if I stick around they'll see how awesome I am and change their mind like, I can prove to them that I'm a really
Great person and I would make a great partner
But not today satan, today, I say...
Okay, well
I totally understand that but I'm actually looking for a commitment and I can't just like hang out with people without developing feelings so,
I'll have to bow out but it was really nice getting to know you
I was so proud of myself you guys
and I know it doesn't seem like a big deal
but this,
This is me knowing that I am worthy of being committed to
In the past, my usual MO has been that "I'll stick around,"
confident that I'm gonna grow on them like a barnacle and/or fungus, and become so indispensable to their life that they can't help but make me their girlfriend,
but not anymore! I have listened to the universe! I hath leeearnt *Trump gesture*
So for those of you struggling with knowing your value, how do we get here?
Well in therapy, I'm learning about positive resilience.
So my therapist says that our brains pick out our flaws, right?
We're designed to look for the negative and focus on our weaknesses because it's how we survive
So to cultivate a sense of self-worth, we need to shift that focus onto our strengths, believe in ourselves, and be clear about our values
That means knowing your boundaries, having the courage to speak up for yourself, and finding ways to validate yourself from within,
Instead of externally. That one I haven't quite figured out yet because I love attention. Now
I know this is all very abstract. Right? Like how do we get to this practically?
well
There are many ways and you can find the ones that speak to you,
whether that's taking the Clifton strengths assessment and taking a moment to reflect every week about how you
exhibited your strengths, therefore doing one rep and mentally solidifying positive resilience, or you can write
affirmations over and over again to take advantage of the link between what we write down, and how we affect our subconscious beliefs.
you can explore these issues in therapy: future- self journal to shift your patterns, and/or listen to guided meditations
one thing you must absolutely do is give yourself time, measure change in six -month increments, sometimes year increments
because when you're in the muck of day-to-day journaling or repeating affirmations in the mirror,
I'M BEAUTIFUL! I'M BEAUTIFUL! I'M BEAUTIFUL!
It can be hard to really see whether or not it's working,
but after you've been at it for a substantial amount of time, when the opportunity arises, you'll see whether or not you're making progress.
So do not be discouraged, because before you know it, you will see the difference.
I want a relationship with you
and also you
and you
NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT
Aye!
look at us!
Yaas
oh my God *chatter* *chatter*
I'm Anna Akana, thank you to CARE OF for sponsoring today's video
Because I am both a vegetarian and a bit of a health nut, every day
I take the multivitamin, probiotic and biotin for ma hair n' nails
vitamins to me have always been like
Insurance, in case I get too stressed out and I haven't eaten what I need to, or if I'm not paying attention to
my protein sources and being a junk food vegetarian
I definitely notice a difference in my sleep quality and my mood when I'm getting what my body needs
But I know that figuring out what your body needs can be annoying and overwhelming, So CARE OF makes vitamins easy
You just take a five-minute quiz and they suggest which vitamins you need based on your dietary requirements and lifestyle
They also have some new veggie protein powders and on the go sticks that I am living for
prices start at just 20 dollars a month and vary depending on your personalized pack the first 200 people to click the link in the
Description can use my code and get 25% off their first month.
Bye
I LOVE YOU ANNA